[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
l'audition publique dernières semaines
avant le choix crucial du 24 avril 2022
avec en point d'orgue de cette semaine
évidemment le débat marine le pen
emmanuel macron m 10 soit à suivre sur
les chaînes parlementaires bien sûr
avant cela nous vous proposons ce soir
de juger chaque projet dans une
trentaine de minutes celui du
rassemblement national est tout de suite
celui du président candidat emmanuel
macron que vous présenter ce soir
bonsoir clément bonne jeu merci beaucoup
à vous d'être d'être là ce soir vous
êtes chargé des affaires européennes
dans ce qui restera le dernier
gouvernement du président macron est ce
qu'il sera réélu on verra ça ce soir
mais c'est vrai que l'écart est assez
faible encore entre les deux finalistes
par rapport à 2017 on rappelle 66 34
c'était l'écart de 2017 je parlais du
débat ça va être un moment qui aura son
importance sans doute
quel est le risque principal qui guette
emmanuel macron dans cette confrontation
très attendue
je sais pas et hiérarchiser les risques
mais l'élection n'est pas jouée elle est
ouverte par définition et le débat est
un élément important dans la dernière
ligne droite d'explication longue
approfondie et du choix du français donc
le risque c'est de ne pas arriver à
convaincre suffisamment de ne pas
arriver à expliquer de manière qu'ils
créent l'adhésion suffisamment pour
réunir une majorité j'espère une large
majorité pour cette élection c'est très
important contre l'extrême droite donc
ce sera un moment de clarification
d'explication de pédagogie de
confrontation démocratique moi je attend
cela avec impatience parce que je pense
que c'est le moment non seulement qu est
une forme de tradition républicaine mais
où il ya dans le détail la confrontation
des projets alors ça c'est l'enjeu
général on va dire l'enjeu pour emmanuel
macron il a dominé largement en 2017
avait été important et a gagné
d'ailleurs des points très vite dans la
foulée
on parle de lui comme d'un président
souvent enfin les français je le trouve
parfois arrogant il pourrait avoir un
excès de confiance de ce point de vue là
est ce qu'on pensait que il fera
attention oui je crois vraiment je crois
pas du tout que
candidat et macron aborde ce débat en se
disant que les choses sont simples
faciles que tout va aller de son côté et
qu' il n'y aura pas de discussion et de
confrontation difficile à avoir au
contraire ce sera un moment compliqué au
bon sens du terme où il faudra pied à
pied défendre un projet répondre à des
attaques ce sens j'espère courtois et
républicains du terme mais des attaques
politiques et je ne m'attends pas à
quelque chose qui soit une promenade de
santé mais on a prouvé le candidat
macron approuvé il y a cinq ans que dans
2 heures et quelques de discussions et
de confrontation était capable
d'expliquer et de convaincre donc il n'y
a pas de raison non plus regarder les
choses avec appréhension on verra alors
après coup nicolas sarkozy dans son
débat face à françois hollande pour sa
tentative de réélection avait dit je
suis arrivé j'étais rincé c'est ce qu'il
avait dit avec un quinquennat de crise
aussi derrière derrière lui ce que ça
c'est un problème que c'est un enjeu
bien sûr quand vous êtes un candidat
président sortant
d'être forcément plus fatigué parce que
vous avez une double casquette
inévitablement le prendre la république
encore jeudi dernier en tentant de
prendre la république qu'il a parlé au
président ukrainien monsieur hinse qui
il a des contacts internationaux
plusieurs fois par semaine qui continue
et il fait en même temps campagne est
une campagne en plus qui a été forcément
un peu écrasée par là il était
international notamment dans le premier
tour et donc il a s'est beaucoup déployé
il est le contacter si la dépouille
l'énergie voyez il a utilisé du temps
j'étais avec vous vous trouvez à sebourg
dire vous le connaissez bien vous avez
des contacts réguliers pour trouver
qu'il a suffisamment de fraîcheur entre
agyness qu'il a de l'énergie et je crois
qu'il aura à coeur parce que c'est un
exercice physique pas pratique et moi
même je pense que tant qu'on a peu fait
soi même ne peut pas vraiment juger mais
enfin je les ai vus de près la dernière
fois et cette fois-ci tout le monde le
dit c'est un exercice physique et donc
je crois qu'ils se préparent aussi en
ménageant un moment de réflexion de
deux pauses en quelque sorte et de repos
physique c'est important alors je
voulais vous soumettre la vous rappeler
la une du jdd ça vous a pas échappé ya
rejet contre roger il ya de ça est ce
que c'est
confrontation entre une forme de rejet
contre une autre forme de rejet marine
le pen emmanuel macron moi je me reste
je ne suis ni sourds et aveugles union
dans le pays il ya une colère et un
rejet multiforme parfois difficile
d'ailleurs à canaliser en quelque sorte
on l'a vu dans d'autres circonstances au
moment de la crise des gilet jaune ça
existe encore d'ailleurs ça existe
beaucoup de démocraties occidentales et
européennes mais moi je ne suis pas dans
cette idée qui consisterait à être
négatif non pas par naïveté mais parce
que on est dans un moment en tant que
responsable politique soutien du
candidat macron c'est aussi ma
responsabilité il faut qu'on explique ce
qu'il ya de positif dans un projet sur
l'écologie sur la jeunesse sur l'école
sur l'europe donc moi je rejette le
projet de marine le pen je vais essayer
d'expliquer merci donné l'occasion sur
certains éléments fondamentaux notamment
l'europe mais je crois j'adhère au
projet de mails macro on est dans un
deuxième tour d'élection présidentielle
c'est le choix de l'essentiel est donc
évidemment évidemment il y à un choix
parfois difficiles à faire il ya des
gens qui vont voter j'espère massivement
pour emmanuel macron en adhérant pas à
100 % peut-être même pas à cinq à
soixante dix où 80% de son projet doit
nous rappeler que c'est un choix
relatifs à bien sûr mais avant
d'accueillir tant parce que dans une
démocratie j'entends quelques étudiants
on a parfois un peu monté en épingle les
choses mais qui disent ni ni ça n'existe
pas ni dans une démocratie il ya des
gens qui nous dirigent quand il ya des
gens qu'on appelle un disque ne pas
choisir c'est choisir aussi mais ne
parte ailleurs oui bien sûr ne pas
choisir ou ne pas vouloir se salir les
mains c'est en fait refusé le jeu
démocratique bon vous savez j'ai voté
pour la première fois à une élection
présidentielle je m'en souviens très
bien il ya vingt ans exactement en 2002
j'avais voté pour lionel jospin au
premier tour on sait ce qui est arrivé
j'ai voté pour les sharks sans la
moindre hésitation deuxième tour c'était
pas mon favori c'était pas mon candidat
mais je savais que j'avais beaucoup plus
en commun avec ce qu'il proposait à
l'époque qu'avec le père le pen bon eh
bien je sais que c'est difficile de ne
pas avoir toute la satisfaction
politique qu'on souhaite il y aura
d'autres échéances mai ne pas agir ne
pas participer ne pas vouloir si je puis
dire se salir les mains au sens
philosophique du terme c'est refuser la
démocratie et on en à crucialement
besoins en avant vous allez peut-être
pouvoir défendre en tout cas vous
défendre d'une accusation qui a été
formulée par dominique de villepin vous
connaissez bien en tout cas c'est un
ancien ministre vous êtes au quai
d'orsay il a été aussi on s'en souvient
bien
brigitte boucher et thème traduit vont
vous interroger sur sur le sur le projet
voilà ce qu'a dit dominique de villepin
je vais voter emmanuel macron puis mais
alors il a dressé un réquisitoire
terrible en disant que emmanuel macron
c'était le risque d'effritement social
de dévoiement sociales diplomatiques ou
culturelles s'il était réélu des
soutiens comme ça vous en seriez pas ces
manifestions pas un soutien de
l'adhésion il le dit lui même donc moi
je ne partage pas sion diagnostic
j'essaye j'espère qu'on va en parler
parce que je vais en parler mais très
positive règlement sur la justice
sociale en train beaucoup parlé le
renforcement de notre hôpital public et
de beaucoup de services publics j'y
crois profondément dominique de villepin
le droit de de ne pas adhérer mais il
fait exactement ce que je décrivais
c'est à dire qu'il prend ses
responsabilités il est un citoyen libre
et n'est pas sur les positions
politiques évidemment ce vraiment
racines et après la vie démocratique
continue par des élections
parlementaires par un certain nombre de
droits d'expression dans le respect des
règles et de la collectivité mais quand
vous voyez ce qui se passe à nos portes
ne pas se servir de la démocratie je
crois que c'est une faute alors tam et
brigitte en a justement parlé de la
question sociale et si vous tapiez
commencé avec les retraites et oui les
retraites la retraite à 65 ans est l'une
des mesure symbole qu'on a retenu
notamment avant le premier tour emmanuel
macron parler de retraite à 65 ans en
2030 on l'a entendu parler dans
l'entre-deux-tours maintenant de
retraite à 64 ans en 2027 est ce que ce
n'est pas un fort recul non alors il a
expliqué je crois précisément les choses
si je peux préciser les dates pas de
clause de rendez-vous en 2028 quelle est
la logique
la mesure et sa logique de fond c'est de
repousser l'âge légal par tranches que
quatre mois par année qui va venir oui
et donc entre si on commence en 2023 le
temps de voter cette forme si les
maquereaux et élus et si le parlement à
cette majorité ça fera à partir des 62
ans actuel un âge légal qui atteint 64
ans si mes calculs sont bons en 2028
près six ans plus tard et il a dit il
faudra sans doute aller jusqu'à 65 mais
y aura une clause de rendez-vous pour
évaluer le système notamment
sur le plan de son équilibre financier
ont fait pas ça pour le plaisir on fait
ça pour assurer le financement du régime
des retraites des avancées sociales
supplémentaires j'y tiens beaucoup je
crois que c'est très important le
programme notamment revaloriser les
petites pensions à 1100 euros minimum et
prendre en compte parce qu'on va
différencier aussi rien n'est fait car
pourquoi rien ne change
on a d'abord obtenu 65 ans pourquoi pas
remis d'abord l'accent sur 65 ans et
puis 64 ans si bien que c'est parce que
situation difficile un prélèvement mais
quand on dit que rien ne change c'est
que le calendrier n'a pas changé
qu'est-ce qui change quand il a dit jean
temps et on va pouvoir négocier qu'est
ce qui est à négocier puisque ça c'était
déjà dans le texte eu lieu il ya une
focalisation sur sept ce paramètre des
65 ans ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron en
déplaçant à denain dès la semaine
dernière et tout au long de la semaine
c'est d'abord regardons la réforme dans
son ensemble telle qu'elle avait été
conçue dès le départ avant le premier
tour parce qu'il n'ya pas que les 65 ans
et la pénibilité les carrières longues
pour des gens qui auront commencé à
travailler tôt il faudra là dessus une
négociation sociale voilà les critères
de pénibilité je vais fini parce que
c'est très important d'avoir la visite
complète on n'a pas assez vu quoi ça
c'est très important c'était dès le
départ le problème ça n'a pas été vu
passer bien expliqué peu importe il faut
le dire et puis revaloriser j'insiste
beaucoup parce que c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il faut travailler davantage au total
financé mieux les petites pensions
passer de 980 euros 2 minimum
aujourd'hui dix ans à 1100 euros est ce
qu a dit emmanuel macron c'est que la
réforme c'était pas 60 50 tout de suite
comme ça ait pu être dit ou compris
c'était sur une plage longue d'une
dizaine d'années que c'est donc quatre
mois par an pour repousser l'âge légal
et qui aurait une clause de rendez-vous
il peut y avoir un peu de souplesse sur
ce paramètre à 64 ans atteint en 2000 28
revenant là ce qui est la cohérence
complète du projet et cette modalité de
rendez-vous en 2028 talons de la
pénibilité vous avez supprimé en 2018
quatre critères de pénibilité ce que
vous allez remettre après les avoir
supprimées quels sont les critères qui
vont être retenues je peux pas vous dire
les critères exacts puisqu'ils c'est
précisément ce là dessus qu'on veut
faire une négociation notamment avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
pourquoi il y avait une suppression des
critères précédents de pénibilité au
début du mandat parce que de l'avis
général c'est une usine à gaz les
syndicats eux mêmes souvent disait on
sait pas comment ça marche des personnes
qui s'apprêtaient à prendre leur
retraite ou qui se pro dans leur
retraite ne savait pas comment ça
marchait qui avaient droit qu'il n'y
avait pas droit pour les supprimer
complètement et parce qu'on n'était pas
dans une réforme globale des retraites
vous a pas totalement échapper qu'on a
essayé d'en faire une que c'était une
des possibilités dans la négociation qui
était ouverte après le blocage de la
réforme proposée par edouard philippe
maintenant on remet les choses avec un
choix démocratique qu'est celui de
l'après en ciel sur la table et donc ça
fait partie parce que là je crois que
c'est juste sinon ce ne serait pas juste
de prendre en compte oui les carrières
longues et oui la pénibilité il faudra
trouver autre chose que des critères
trop compliqué qui ne protégeait
personne que ce qui avait été mise en
place à vous rappelez vous remettez en
cause tous les régimes spéciaux
alors les régimes spéciaux oui ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui ils seront remis en
cause pour les intégrer dans un système
général ça veut pas dire parce que il
faut être précis sur le langage qu'on
emploie toutes les situations
particulières d'abord parce qu'il y aura
encore une fois carrières longues et
pénibilité à prendre en compte c'est pas
lié à un employeur particulier ou un
métier spécifique ou un statut et puis
il ya des situations particulières on
l'a déjà dit de la campagne vient
insiste par exemple les personnes en
situation de handicap elles ont un droit
à la retraite à 55 ans aujourd'hui on le
préservera les spécificités qui seront
bien sûr prise en compte a dit alors
emmanuel macron s'est dit prêt à revoir
l'attribution de la hache c'est
l'allocation adulte handicapée elle
serait individualisé alors
qu'aujourd'hui elle dépend des revenus
du conjoint pourquoi cette volte-face
alors que le président a toujours dit
non pendant tout le quinquennat pourquoi
cela n'avait pas été fait pour dans une
logique je puis dire un peu rapide
peut-être de logique de justice fiscale
de justice dans les revenus quand une
personne en situation de handicap est
marié à une autre personne qui n'est pas
dans cette situation peu importe qui
gagne très bien sa vie il n'est pas
complètement logique de se dire
allocations et pour aider financièrement
une personne qui a des difficultés
d'accès à l'emploi ou autre la situation
du couple permet de faire face à ses
difficultés ce qu'a entendu je crois que
c'était dit avec émotion faut aussi
l'entendre dans ces moments là sur le
plateau de vos confrères de france info
je crois vendredi face au candidat
emmanuel macron c'est que les gens qui
n'étaient pas une question de revenus
c'est une question un peu comptable de
justice fiscale c'est une question de
dignité
la dame toutes les oppositions lyon 10
pendant 50 les publicains le parti
communiste ont fait des propositions de
loi toute l'opposition était contre la
majorité lila il cède parce qu'il est
devant une personne en situation de
handicap acquis cède il a entendu un
argument qu'il a peut-être je crois
qu'on doit voir sa cohérence mais alors
il est bien éloigné des réalités quand
il est allé dire elle est pas bien
éloignées des réalités l'allocation
adulte handicapée elle a été
significativement revalorisé on peut pas
résumer la protection des personnes en
situation de handicap leur
accompagnement pour d'autres à l'école
pour les plus jeunes générations à cette
seule question mais oui il ya eu vous
savez c'est comme ce qu'on vient
discuter sur les retraites tout en
gardant sa cohérence et son fils rouges
quand il ya des incompréhensions quand
il ya des choses qui même peut-être sont
rationnels mais suscite chez les
personnes qu'on essaie de protéger ou
d'accompagner une colère un malaise un
malentendu il faut entendre aussi mais
l'émotion des malades macron ça va
suffire à tenir une promesse sur un
quinquennat c'est l'émotion c'est pas
simplement l'émotion point à la ligne
c'est une discussion qu'il ya eu un
engagement qu'il a pris en tant que
candidat et donc il y aura si une
majorité parlementaire qui va dans ce
sens un ajustement législatives mal à
voir autre chose qu'une mesures
clientélistes
pardon mais du coup la politique depuis
peu de temps mais il ya une chose que je
vois c'est bien c'est que soit vous
n'écoutez jamais vous ne changez jamais
d'avis et vous êtes fermé avant mais
peut-être je veux bien battre ma coulpe
et dire qu'il ya des choses qu'on aurait
pu faire mieux plus tôt les entendre
plus facilement je crois que la
cohérence d'un projet social économique
politique on l'a qu'il y ait sur des
sujets n'ont pas la marge mais important
sensible
des corrections je crois que ça fait
aussi partie d'un projet politique
surtout dans la second tour c'est un
tour on a entendu des critiques on peut
les trouver injuste qu'on ait des
responsables politiques et qu'on
al'impression leur fait beaucoup de
choses mais peu importe ce n'est pas
notre ressenti qui compte c'est aussi
celui des français on a entendu dans un
deuxième tour qui avait des projets plus
sociaux plusieurs gauches plus
écologiste terra qui avaient été
scellées lue par 1,2 million
aussi on retient ce que vous dites c'est
une correction maintenant on va parler
de la législation actuelle et de leurs à
votre porte à ce sujet
cette campagne marine le pen dit qu'elle
va changer l'europe de l'intérieur
qu'elle va convaincre en allant à
bruxelles vous dit que c'est impossible
de changer les règles mais ce que vous
vous n'avez pas qu'est ce que vous dites
alors non je vous le souvenir mais c'est
impossible de changer des règles
d'accord parce qu'elle veut le dire elle
dit qu'elle va pouvoir changer la
contribution par exemple de la france au
budget de l'union européenne
jusqu'ici la république en mer jeudi que
ce n'est pas possible de négocier ça
comme ça mais justement parce que vous
n'avez pas vous réussi à faire changer
justement des choses en europe l'europe
de la défense les gars femmes même si ce
n'est pas complètement arrivé à terme
sur la taxe carbone par exemple donc
est-ce que c'est pas possible justement
de faire changer et bien le la
contribution de la france au budget de
l'union européenne par exemple changer
l'europe c'est notre bilan et c'est
notre projet casser l'europe c'est celui
madame le pen pourquoi parce que moi je
dit jamais qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative
il jamais qui a pas de choix
démocratiques les français peuvent
choisir marine le pen et marine le pen
peut avoir ce projet là simplement je
dis il faut montrer avec transparence
honnêteté cohérence séquelles ce projet
comment ça marche nous on a dit par
exemple il ya cinq ans un seul exemple
sur le travail des tâches et dumping
social en europe on va créer des
coalitions on va se battre on va hausser
le ton ça arrive aussi dans la
négociation en peine c'était le premier
conseil européen des mails macron en a
obtenu trois mois plus tard une réforme
ultra détachées parce que moi même le
président de la république s'est déplacé
en europe à construire des alliances a
fait des compromis voilà c'est comme ça
que ça marche madame le pen elle dit pas
ça elle dit je vais aller à bruxelles et
alors on contribue tout symbole commun
quel budget européen on a négocié il ya
deux ans divers ouvrir la négociation
l'a dit d'ailleurs même pas tout à fait
ça dit je vais baisser de 5 milliards
d'euros 5 milliards dans bach la
contribution française il ya d'autres
pays qui souhaitent la même ville
d'abord il c'est toujours plus
sympathique de moins payer de plus
recevoir ça d'accord mais après la vraie
vie quand vous êtes en collectivité la
france est une collectivité l'europe
d'une collectivité de démocratie
souveraine il faut discuter avec les
autres ça peut pas être négocié mais si
mais très bien donc madame le pen
j'essaie de comprendre son plan moi
aussi c'est pas toujours claire elle dit
le lendemain je vais à bruxelles déjà on
a un peu changé de tonalité et je vais
dire je veux m'en payer moins au budget
européen très bien donc soit vous avez
des alliés pour l'instant les alliés
madame le pen ça se résume à monsieur
sorbonne elle confond soit la carte soit
les numéros de téléphone puisqu'elle a
dit que prémices slovaque était son
allié l'a fait un tweet pour dire ils
n'avaient rien en commun que même le
plan qu'elle a peu d'alliés vous
reconnaîtrez ce fait bon ha ben en état
en tout cas très bien ça fait 2 sur 27
dont qu'on commence difficilement la
négociation la négociation par ailleurs
elle a eu lieu il ya deux ans donc ça
c'est pas le truc le plus chaud le plus
facile à changer soit le dit il faut
qu'elle précise cela le débat on sera
peut-être l'occasion bassim entendent
pas c'est pas grave je ferai moi-même
mais très bien si elle fait le même si
elle dit je fais moins cinq milliards
sur mon chèque croyais que l'allemagne
ne fera pas pareil pour être l'italie ne
fera pas pareil et on fait quoi c'est
quoi c'est l'implosion l'union
européenne ça veut dire se voit elle
respecte les règles il renégocie mais
c'est une inflexion très significative
ça veut dire simplement qu'elle veut
s'inscrire à démocratie européenne enfin
ces députés européens vont bosser au
parlement européen et voter les textes
qu'elle veut négocier avec le chancelier
allemand et d'autres et obtenir des
compromis c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est
pour ça que tant mieux si elles
plébiscitent notre projet changer europe
l'honneur c'est nous ils faisons mais si
elle dit mes alliés il n'existe pas ça
sera victor hoban c'est un peu court je
vais décider tout seul ça c'est là que
je dis qu'ils afrique 6,2 cacher parce
que décider tout seul sans renégociation
en s'affranchissant des règles communes
c'est comme quand vous vivez dans une
copropriété dans une commune dans une
démocratie est a commencé son idée vous
sortez sans le dire de la collectivité
c'est tout moi je n'ai aucun problème
avec le fait qu'elle veuille le frac
site mais qu'elle le dise une autre
mesure jordan par des la dic emmanuel
macron attend le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle pour que
l'union européenne annonce finalement
l'embargo russe sur le pétrole qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez
je répond d'abord puisqu'il a cité un
article du new york times tout part de
là l'union européenne attend
effectivement dit aussi qu'il ya un
grand danger du rassemblement national
mais d'après un bout du journal qui
l'intéressait bon monsieur bart des lacs
et député européen ce qu'un homme
extraordinaire il ne sait pas que ça
fait plus d'un mois que ce sujet sur la
table du parlement européen et des états
membres donc allez crie au complot quand
on fait soi même pas son travail
d'information et transparent
démocratique c'est un peu inquiétant ce
que vous êtes vous dit c'est pas trop
mal aux russes
pour vous je viens sur le fond depuis le
sommet de versailles qui avait lieu en
mars en france où présidence de l'union
européenne il y à cette option bien sûr
pourquoi parce que nous mettons des
sanctions très dures que le
rassemblement national toujours refusé
contre la russie les oligarques des
secteurs économiques nous avons fait ça
par étapes il ya quatre paquets de
sanction peu importe exactement mais
c'est important et vous voyez bien
malheureusement convient encore une
situation affreuse en ukraine que la
russie intensifier les frappes et donc
il y aura sans doute de nouveau train de
sanctions ça se décide à l'unanimité des
vingt-sept donc le président aulas
présent de la république française aura
son mot à dire le moment venu le
calendrier n'a aucun rapport avec
l'élection présidentielle d'abord parce
qu'il ya 27 pays si on attendait les
élections de chacun on travaillera
jamais et puis parce que des sanctions
dans la prise il comprit quelques heures
avant le premier tour ans plaidera pour
ça je dis oui nous pensons que c'est une
des options s'est pas décidé mais ces
défections
annoncées très abondante les sanctions a
pas de pouvoir d'achat on le voit déjà
sur les prix alimentaires c'est pour ça
qu'on prend un bouclier de protection
même si les prix de l'énergie avaient
commencé à augmenter indépendamment de
la guerre c'était déjà un mouvement
amorcé donc oui on les ferme
contrairement rassemblement national
contre monsieur poutine parce que c'est
l'horreur qui se passe en ukraine donc
un peu de décence un peu de cohérence
mais bien sûr nous protégerons quelles
que soient les mesures qui ne sont pas
encore en l'occurrence décider quelles
que soient les mesures le pouvoir
d'achat des français par des mesures
comme on l'a fait une pièce d'une ultime
question de demande d'être très très
bref dans la réponse partouche a défendu
les critères de maastricht en 2017 on
vous entend moins sur cette question là
en 2022 est ce que vous avez changé
d'avis et ce que vous êtes prêt à
laisser filer un peu la dette et le
déficit alors je conteste un peu le
postulat parce que je travaillais pour
un ministre de l'économie il ya quelques
années que sa plaie mal macron
qu'avaient dit les 3% sont stupides il
faut des règles budgétaires mais ça fait
longtemps qu'on porte leurs révisions et
qu on dit même qu'il faut casser leur
taux d'oxygène sur certains sujets en
trente deux communes étaient voyant
quand même au début du quinquennat on
était très proche des 3 % et c'était
dans le programme c'était assumé on a
dit en 2017 il faut de tenir l'objectif
3% c'est une question aussi je l'assumé
de crédibilité pas seulement pour faire
plaisir à berlin bruxelles mais pour la
tenue de nos comptes est en période de
crise c'est aussi parce que nous avons
réduit la dette et le déficit avant
qu'on a pu faire le quoi qu'il en coûte
mais sur le on a 600 milliards de dettes
en plus mais je crois que c'était
nécessaire et on a pu avec une signature
sur les marchés financiers en empruntant
à touba le faire parce qu'on avait
maîtriser les déficits avant du coup
l'objectif dans ce sport pour cent des
t3 pour ça ce sont les règles actuelles
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faudra sans
doute maintenant il ya la guerre en plus
qui
sans doute nécessitera des mesures
économiques importantes dans les
semaines qui viennent oui révisait le
pacte de stabilité et de croissance je
ne crois pas tellement au totem du 3% et
du 60% je pense que c'est plutôt sans
être trop technique des règles de
rapidité du retour à ses grands
équilibres qu'il faut ajuster changer et
surtout surtout dégager des marges de
manoeuvre peut-être en dehors de ces
seuils pour l'investissement notamment
dans la transition de merci merci
beaucoup clément bonne pas facile de
toujours d'être synthétique sur des
questions techniques merci brigitte
merci comme une question avant
d'accueillir yves thréard il ya un
décret paru aujourd'hui au journal
officiel qui déchaîne les oppositions
notamment celle du rassemblement
national et qui prévoit la suppression
du corps diplomatique non il y aura
désormais vivier de fonctionnaires si je
puis dire c'est pas très heureux mais
c'est comme ça de haut fonctionnaire qui
ensuite seront affectés un certain
nombre d'administrations votre entrée
théâtrale bonjour il alors à quelques
jours c'est ce que dit marine le pen à
quelques jours emmanuel macron vont
remplacer des serviteurs de l'état
impartiaux part du copinage est ce que
c'est ça effectivement est ce que ce
seront des nominations à discrétion de
celui qui gouverne mensonge grossier les
règles de nomination par ion de nos
ambassadeurs elles sont fixées par la
constitution elle ne change en rien en
rien nous avons transformé l'ena en un
institut national de service public
recrutement par concours tous nos
fonctionnaires sont recrutés par une
voix méritocratique celle de concours
diplomates ou autre je suis au
fonctionnaire je suis passé par cette
voie j'y tiens beaucoup et cela restera
en changeant un peu les épreuves mais
cela restera ce qui ce que fait
simplement décret c'est qu'ils cassent
les petites boîtes dans lesquelles on
range les hauts fonctionnaires quand
vous êtes dans un ministère aujourd'hui
notamment le quai d'orsay vous ne pouvez
pas aller facilement à un autre
ministère travaillé quelques années une
situation sont figés il n'y a pas de
mobilité et réciproquement quand vous
venez du ministère des finances est très
difficile d'aller au ministère des
affaires étrangères la seule chose que
ça change c'est plus de fluidité de
mobilité dans les carrières des hauts
fonctionnaires en gardant les règles de
nomination en gardant le concours aucun
copinage rien ne change à cet égard en
tant que ça de la part de madame le pen
qui a créé une structure familiale où
ces connivences et copinage à tous les
étages c'est quand même un peu fort de
karaj à pâques marine le pen mais
salaires ranger quand même
situation il ya toujours des routines et
des habitudes parfois les gens à mieux
rester dans l'administration qu'ils
connaissent je les ai vécu aussi comme
fonctionnaire mais il faut je crois dans
l'intérêt collectif et dans l'intérêt
des hauts fonctionnaires à voir aussi ré
de la mobilité de la respiration dans sa
carrière yves thréard c'est à vous
bonjour clément garde encore le bruit de
mon entrée
samedi le président de la république
était en campagne à marseille et alors
on a écouté un discours
d'un écologiste convaincu et on s'est
dit tiens bien virage écolo la
destinée à plaire à l'électorat de
monsieur mélenchon qui est un peu
évident
alors moi je crois pas au virage écolo
si vous me permettez bon cela il ya un
discours écologique très engagé à
marseille pagnol je crois que c'était
nécessaire mais je crois que le
président a ressenti aussi maintenant
y'a parce qu'on voit bien que c'était
les préoccupations notamment pas
seulement lectorat de jean luc mélenchon
mais de la jeunesse en france et on
entend moi je l'entends tout le temps
cette critique vous avez pas fait assez
n'allait pas assez vite vous n'êtes pas
assez colossal longtemps mais ce qu'a
dit le président et le candidat
d'ailleurs c'est de défendre un bilan je
veux pas être trop long mais quand même
c'est très important moi je m'occupe des
affaires européennes on est le pays et
c'est pas un objectif de papier qui a
défini conduit l'europe a adopté la
neutralité en émissions de gaz à effet
de serre neutralité carbone en 2050
aujourd'hui on l'intègre tous nos
secteurs économiques cette jeunesse dont
vous parlez est le fait le reproche
justement emmanuel macron a laissé vie
la dalle est d'avoir un bilan nul sur le
plan écologique et notamment cette
convention citoyenne qui avait été un
des grands espoirs
après la la la la la sphère des gilet
jaune et bien finalement ça a été un
flop total à un gadget complet parce
qu'il n'a pas respecté sa promesse mais
pas du tout ces deux conventions ça a
été trop vu comme ça peut-être même
hersant qu'elle je pense que ce qu'on
n'a pas assez fait pour être très clair
c'est d'expliquer de dire ce qu'on avait
fait qui sait qu'on a la première loi en
europe c'était la loi portée par brune
poirson membres du gouvernement à
l'époque sur l'interdiction du plastique
à usage unique sur la lutte contre le
gaspillage sur le recyclage automatique
de certains pays lui tellement belles
lois qu'elle a été remercié son auteur
je crois pas que ce soit la raison peu
importe sa toile existe aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qui compte au delà des
personnes la loi climat résilience on
peut dire c'est pas parfait c'est pas
assez mais on veut pas dire que rien pas
du tout l'interdiction
qu'elle ne dise pas qu'ils rien mais je
le dis aussi pour nous on n'a pas assez
défendu incarné ce bilan écologique je
le dit avoir été vous avez un regret
mais je vais pas vous dire que tepco
l'agglo pas non mais c'est pas une
question de personne je crois qui sait
aujourd'hui ce café ministre de
l'écologie ce n'est pas le sujet en cinq
ans mais beaucoup sur les affaires
européennes et j'espère qu'on a fait des
choses bien oui donc c'est pas la
question du casting soyons sur le fond
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites sur l'interdiction de grands
projets de contraire à l'environnement
notre dame del en europe à city c'est
pas des petites choses il a fallu
expliquer les conséquences sociales le
candidat macron l'a rappelé samedi quand
on est en europe les premiers à être à
dire qu'on est neutre en carbone en 2050
aujourd'hui on va être le premier
continent à interdire les véhicules
thermiques des petites choses c'est
transformé ce traitement l'industrie
vous allez trouver ce premier ministre
extraordinaire qui a une fibre
environnementale écologique et qui va en
même temps être en charge de ce
programme attendait cette planification
écologique c'est pas un vocabulaire
qu'on a beaucoup dans la dans le conte
entend beaucoup dans la bouche du
président de la république ça aurait pu
libéral que ça quand même hein alors
vous qui êtes un observateur attentif
mais chez traire vous avez noté ou lui
puisque c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans
le programme
produit avant le premier tour que l'idée
de planification écologique était déjà
présente ça ne date pas de dieu ces deux
centres jean luc mélenchon monsieur mais
dream et ça ne date pas du soir du
premier tour c'est important et il y a
en effet au delà du bilan que j'essayais
en quelques mots le défendre il y à des
projets très importants 50 parc éolien
en mer 10 fois la puissance solaire
installée aujourd'hui en europe pour
être justement sur cet objectif de
mettre les personnes qui sauve la
personne qui l'incarnera je ne le sais
pas comme je ne sais pas quel serait le
détail il appartient ce sera le
nom à donner si j'en avais d'ailleurs
dans ma tête je ferais je donnerai
conseils aux candidats au président je
ne veux pas rentrer et mais le président
rémy revient déjà
de trouver un premier ministre en
général ou une femme du niveau d'un
premier ministre et qui en plus soit
écologiste dans le dans l'armée c'est
amusant fonction pré me serait difficile
c'est difficile de trouver quelqu'un de
bien mais c'est pas parce que y'a
l'écologie en plus que mon impression
que ça n'existe pas des gens qui
s'engagent pour l'écologie aux élections
européennes on avait en numéro 2 de la
liste monsieur qu'enfin qu'avait été
muni du gouvernement hollande est un
grand écologiste engagé dernière
question il est très importante au
parlement européen donc c'était des gens
s'ils s'engagent est-ce que vous avez vu
cette consultation qui a été conduite
par monsieur mélenchon auprès de
ccc votants on s'aperçoit finalement que
les deux tiers de ceux qui ont voté pour
lui ne ne compte pas du tout content de
voter nul ou s'abstenir il a qu'un tiers
un petit tiers qui iraient voter pour
monsieur macro d'abord on
verra moi notre boulot le mien celui le
candidat macron c'est de convaincre ceux
qui ont voté mélenchon ou pour l'autre
d'ailleurs de voter pour nous et
l'écologie ont fait partie pascal
inverse madame le pen s'est démantelée
les éoliennes c'est jeter les accords de
paris c'est sortir du green deal
européen qui nous met sur la trajectoire
des accords de paris donc c'est le
climato scepticisme la trump complet
marine le pen et climato sceptiques ce
sera sans doute un des
ailes et elle est contre toutes les
règles européennes qu'on est en train de
mettre en place et elle a parlé de
gourou et de sacro-saintes cap 21 qui a
créé les accords de paris c'est dire le
respect qu hélas pour ses acteurs merci
clément bonne d'être venu ce soir
défendre le programme d' emmanuel macron
bonne soirée merci on vous retrouve dans
un aspect si vous allez être maintenant
remplacée par la représentant du
rassemblement national lors la valette
merci encore à vous merci à vous les
huit matches à bientôt sur la chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]
merci à vous d'être là ce soir vous êtes
conseiller régional de provence alpes
côte d'azur porte parole de marine le
pen finaliste de cette présidentielle
2022 vous remplacez et je vous en
remercie au pied levé philippe ballard
qui devait être là ce soir et qui a été
convoqué utile pour préparer le débat de
marine le pen puisque fait partie de
l'équipe qui prépare ce débat avec
marine le pen est un peu de fébrilité
dans l'entourage de marine le pen tous
fébriles les bas n'ont pas de fébrilité
on est prêt bah il ne fait vous savez
s'y prépare depuis cinq ans maintenant
je crois elle a enjambé après avoir
trébuché un peu en 2010 est elle le dit
elle même qu'elle a
déçu un peu le peuple français vous
savez c'est karine le marchand elle
avait dit est-ce que vous avez déjà déçu
quelqu'un que vous aimez et je pense que
depuis elle n'a de cesse voilà de faire
un bon débat je pense qu'elle est prête
elle est sereine à l'image en fait un
peu de sa campagne depuis le mois de
septembre sur le terrain c'est vrai
qu'elle dit toujours qu'elle est sereine
ça se voit situé à l'écart est faible
dans les sondages mais il est constant
il n'y a pas un seul sondage qui a donné
marine le pen gagnante à ce stade de ce
second tour elle serait battu dimanche
vous allez pouvoir compenser ce retard
je pense oui et puis je pense que le
débat justement va être une bonne une
bonne vitrine pour montrer nos deux
projets qui sont tout à fait différents
en fait si que le français se rendent
compte que d'un coup j'allais dire il ya
deux camps qui se sont dégagés de cette
élection présidentielle comme en 2010
est d'ailleurs avec les mondialistes
d'un côté ceux qui sont pour une
mondialisation une immigration peut peut
maîtriser une mondialisation sauvage
enfin les deux lots de côté voilà des
souverainistes qui sont attachés à la
nation qui pensent que la nation protège
qui sont attachés à leurs frontières et
c'est vrai que ces deux sujets de deux
projets totalement différent à quoi êtes
vous vraiment attaché justement la
question commence à se poser parce que
par exemple sur la question du voile il
ya un changement pied à huit jours du
second tour marine le pen disait encore
vendredi matin que c'était une réforme
un sens instantiel que de d'interdits le
port du voile dans l'espace public elle
avait dit c'est une réforme essentielle
et puis ça me dit interpellé par une
grand mère voilée elle a répondu qu'elle
n'était pas obtuse et on croit
comprendre maintenant que
finalement ça pourrait être discuté par
le parlement et peut être
décrété peut-être à un moment du
quinquennat mais ce n'est pas l'urgence
est ce que marine le pen interdit le
voile le port du voile sur la voie
publique madame martichoux je vous dis
oui je vous dis oui alors c'est un
marqueur 7 c'est une des mesures vous
savez du bouquet de cette loi je
rappelle aux gens qui nous écoutent que
marine le pen a un projet qu'elle va
faire voter par référendum sur
l'immigration la maîtrise de
l'immigration savoir qui va pouvoir
rentrer sur notre sol qui pourra avoir
la nationalité la fin du droit du sol le
regroupement familial et à côté de ça il
a aussi une loi qui a été préparée
notamment avec avec monsieur garraud
vous savez qui a fondé le parquet
antiterroriste pour lutter contre
l'islamisme et du coup l'interdiction du
droit du voile est un des uns des
éléments un des faisceaux avec lequel
nous allons lutter contre l'islamisme en
france donc oui il n'ya pas de
faiblissement c'est un fantasme
journalistique de attendait les
dérogations à 7 il n'y aura pas de
dérogations c'est pas comme ça que ça va
se passer vous savez on n'est pas là
c'est le 17 mai peur mais l'a laissé
entendre à cette date qu'elles ne
seraient pas concernées il y aura
peut-être un certain dicerna dit ça ça
malgré un indice années passées en fait
je pense qu'il ya une grande différence
entre les par exemple est jeune femme de
20 ans qui sont voilées où il ya une
certaine revendications ou alors elles
sont voilées un peu contre leur gré vous
savez quand même moi j'habite à toulon
je peux vous dire qu'il ya une cité un
peu sensible s'appelle la beaucaire à
côté on a quand même beaucoup de
témoignages de femmes voilées qui nous
disent se voiler pour être tranquille
par exemple et ça pose un vrai même au
sein de leurs familles sains vous savez
la pression que brimades et comment vous
allez faire la différence et
effectivement je pense que
c'est pas une histoire d'âme je pense
que ça sera dans un discernement mais
hélas matisse ou juives non mais ça nous
intéresse parce que ça ça fait partie
quand même comme vous dites des
marqueurs un marqueur mais c'est un
marqueur du heat et août on ne voit pas
bien le périmètre d'application
c'est vrai que c'est troublant explique
alain moi disait tout à l'heure c'est
une loi qui va passer dans un processus
législatif comme on en a en france donc
ça a passé à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat à l'assemblée cette loi sera
sûrement amendé et peut-être que ses
modalités pratiques véritablement de
d'application seront peut-être un peu
remise il n'empêche que dans mais on m'a
dit ou pas du tout il n'empêche que nous
ne voulons plus de voix dans l'espace
public parce que nous pensons déjà que
le voile est un peu l'uniforme des
islamistes vous savez quand les talibans
par exemple arrivent au pouvoir ils
voient les femmes c'est une de leurs
premières mesures et il ya aussi une
vraie un vrai souci j'allais dire de
l'égalité homme-femme vous savez bien
que c'est un instrument de soumission de
sable est défendable mais ce qui est
compliqué ce qu'ils troublent votre
interlocuteur si vous lui dites que à la
fois c'est très important et à la fois
on verra non mais je vends ma wii fait
d'abord le référendum ensuite faudra une
loi non je ne peux plus non ça ce qui
est bien c'est une loi qui sera proposé
au parlement le référendum justement il
est sur l'île et à sang il est sur
l'immigration il ce sont deux projets
totalement différent l'un qui va nous
permettre de reprendre la maîtrise de 9
sur un train ter l'interdiction du voile
à part le sur la voie publique sur le
critère de quoi sol comprenant mais
c'est la volonté politique que nous
avons deux dames à lutter contre les
résidents à huy hà critères pardon non
mais vous parce que vous voulez dire un
peu sur l'âge par exemple vous voulez me
demander comment est ce qu'on va faire à
bath mais moi même ce qu'on va faire
appliquer même sur le fond ce que c'est
parce que nous considérons que c'est un
uniforme islamistes oui d'accord mais il
avait créé le 1 je n'ai dit que ça
suffit pas mais non mais une fois que ça
sera la normandie dans une loi mais dame
artichauts que la loi sera votée on
appliquera la loi et je ne sais quand
elle ne doute pas que nos l'interdiction
pourra figurer sur quelques rats mais
regardez je dire quand la burqa par
exemple c'est interdit bien des raisons
de sécurité de ces va et là je vous
l'accordé ça sera la lutte contre l' le
voit c'est plus contre le terrorisme
parce que ce sont six si ça ça sera un
fondement juridique de lutte et de même
qu'on va fermer les mosquées salafistes
vous savez il ya 540 mosquée qui ne
respectent pas le droit d'asile et que
l'on va fermer je vous pose la question
et on va accueillir maintenant brigitte
busch est en train de nuit qui vont vous
interroger sur l'europe et l'économie
mais est ce que dans le fond se bouger
de marine le pen c'est pas parce que
elle s'aperçoit marine le pen que ce
sera très compliqué d'interdire je pense
que la différence de nos opposants il
d'emmanuel macron je vais vous dire
c'est qu'on a une volonté politique et
d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant ce
que vous me dites parce que si on
reprend emmanuel macron il a aussi
là-dessus changer de braquet est ce que
pendant très longtemps il a été contre
le port du voile souvenez vous c'était
une incivilité prenez jean luc mélenchon
qui disait que c'était obscènes et un
autre adjectif pas piqué des vers donc
en fait c'est plutôt eux si vous voulez
qu'ils ont fait un rétropédalage marine
le pen a toujours dit qu'il n'y aurait
plus de voile dans l'espace public parce
que c'est aussi une appropriation
culturel justement de de l'islamisme et
donc si vous voulez ça encore une fois
c'est un marqueur important ce n'est pas
la priorité il ne s'agit pas là
évidemment de 2 vous avez denis de
choquer évidemment ni ni ni de fracture
est simplement nous pensons que nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane
respecteront la loi ce sera peut-être
une question abordée au débat mercredi
soir je vous présente brigitte vous
souhaitez me tran huy on commence par
vous brigitte et on revient justement
sur l'immigration oui je m'en sers lors
la valette marine le pen veut en
priorité un référendum sur l'immigration
pour la priorité nationale or il ya un
consensus des juristes pour dire que ce
n'est pas constitutionnel de faire un
référendum sans passer par le parlement
est ce que votre programme est d'ores et
déjà un faisable non mais sauf qu'avec
l'article 11 il vous de la constitution
il vous a pas échappé mais savait qu'on
ne peut pas faire un sacré mensonge ça
les pouvoirs malheur à ce moment là je
veux dire quid du général de gaulle et
de toutes les élections au suffrage
universel qui sont bien vus
jurisprudence ça sera la même chose
alors à ce moment là pourquoi est-ce que
la jouer cependant ça aurait marché si
vous voulez pour c'est pour la façon
d'élire son président de la république
au à ce moment-là ça voudrait dire que
tous ceux qui ont été élus du coup ne
sont pas
mais vous savez très bien qu'au
lendemain de cette proposition le
conseil constitutionnel va dire non donc
ça ça crée une crise institutionnelle à
peine être arrive au moins je ne pense
pas et vous savez ce programme on l'a
pas écrit tout seul sur un coin de table
de bistrot on a aussi des juristes des
hauts fonctionnaires qui nous ont aidés
à l'ailé l'ensemble des fonctionnalités
les plus connus de la place de paris
disent le contraire
pouvez-vous me savais dès qu'on a une
idée en ce moment c'est quand même assez
marrant surtout entre deux tours dès
qu'on a une idée soit pas applicable
soit les mâles chiffrés soient non je
pense qu'on a la volonté politique est
justement de faire voter ce référendum
qui sera une façon pour les français de
reprendre en main leur politique
migratoire alors qu'on ne leur a pas
posé la question depuis une quarantaine
d'années et justement c'est
effectivement c'est un bouleversement et
je pense que ça va être une grande
différence de projets avec emmanuel
macron sauf que vous allez un peu contre
notre état de droit où je ne pense pas
je vous assure que ça va très très bien
se passer et que vous ayez politique
d'aller contre l'état de droit non la
parole au nom jédir s'agit d'un régime
par exemple du tout d'accord on y voit
presque un coup d'état pas du tout
excusez moi est-ce que général de gaulle
à 162 c'était un coup d'état quand ça a
été fait parce que vous aimez depuis
dix jours ils ont besoin explique
c'était pas possible avant qu'il
jurisprudence il a bien fait ça et ça a
très bien fonctionné
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi ça ne
marcherait pas ok qu'est ce que vous
dites à ceux qui pensent que votre
programme et raciste car avec la
priorité nationale vous remettez en
cause l'égalité des citoyens devant la
loi voilà vous y allez fort quand même
on remet pas en cause d'égalité des
citoyens devant la loi il se trouve que
il ya certaines allocations de
solidarité comme par exemple les
allocations familiales qui sont là pour
relancer la natalité d'un pays et qui
effectivement ne
bénéficierons qu'aux personnes fako
qu'aux français ou qu'aux familles dans
l'un des deux parents est français la
même chose va se poser pour le rsa ou
pour le cas de deux catégories de
citoyens finalement ah bah oui madame
enfin il ya les français et ceux qui ne
sont pas francs français est
effectivement avec enfants c'est une
constitution et de la légalité citoyens
devant la loi sans distinction d'origine
de l'instruction publique schelin de
l'audition publique les gens qui votent
c'est quand même marrant ça les gens
qu'il faut être français pour pour voter
on a à peu près devant le même cas de
figure avec les les étrangers qui n'ont
pas la nationalité française qu'ils ne
peuvent pas voter et ceux qui peuvent
voter et encore une fois c'est après de
l'antériorité non mais donner la
priorité aux français dans leur pays
leur maison ils n'en ont qu'une et ça
nous paraît tout mais même si un
étranger bayer qui payent des
cotisations ça c'est justement ce que
vous dites quand on paye des cotisations
sociales à ce moment là on a des
allocations qui sont contributives et là
évidemment bien sûr qu'ils n'en
bénéficieront de même que pour les
allocations de solidarité comme le rsa
ou les apl si la personne qui étrangères
sur notre sol arrive à justifier de 5 en
équivalent temps plein il bénéficiera au
même titre de ces allocations tam là
vous prévoyez aussi d'interdire ou de
limiter le regroupement familial selon
des critères stricts d'abord est-ce que
c'est interdire ou est-ce que c'est
limité alors c'est interdit a aussi
interdire après on n'est pas à l'abri
qui est un cas de cas qu'ils soient
absolument terrible avec laquelle on ne
puisse pas moralement arriver à faire ce
regroupement familial mais non nous
sommes contre le regroupement familial
je sais que c'est c'est une polémique
qui a été pas mal un peu monté notamment
par l'examen c'est bien mais d'un
programme trouver ces qui a marqué les
banques et interdire mais je vous assure
qu elle invitait selon des critères
drastiques mans ne laissant que très
très peu de j'allais dire de commandes
mais c'est ça pour être quoi des cas où
on pourrait
des cas dramatiques jeu de personnes
malades qui auraient besoin je sais pas
à l'article de la mort de revoir leurs
parents
c'est interdit c'est interdit bien sûr
mais en fait ça vous savez nous avons
aussi un petit coeur quand même j'ai
revu les autres partis politiques n'ont
pas le monopole du coeur est
effectivement voilà mais sur
en faites pas vos coups de coeur non je
suis je suis pas sûr je pense que c'est
avoir du coeur pour les français en feng
pour les gens qui sont déjà là il vous a
pas échappé qu'un français sur quatre ne
mange pas à sa faim canfin voilà que les
français renoncent à des à des soins
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à joindre
les deux bouts n'arrive pas à faire le
plein d'essence dans leur voiture donc
non je pense que justement c'est avoir
du meilleur pour les gens alors on déjà
ceux là encore on va pas essayer de
rentrer dans exactement le même débat
monsieur droit il est protégé par la cee
dh par la constitution par une directive
européenne de 2003 par le droit
international avec l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant là encore que moi ce que
vous ferez vous allez voir qu'on va très
bien s'en sortir parce qu'encore une
fois on aura de la volonté politique et
que ce référendum une fois qu'il sera
voté par les français figurez vous que
le peuple est souverain et que justement
cette souveraineté on la retrouve dans
notre constitution est justement les
traités européens qui auront j'allais
dire un esprit tout à fait contraire au
droit souverain ne seront pas appliquées
on va parler de l'europe en tout à
l'heure votre loi prévoit rester de
conditionner vous venez d'en parler
prestations de solidarité à cinq années
de travail en france c'est seulement
temps plein voilà c'est pas forcément
cinq ans constituait un consécutif vous
estimez les économies à 16 milliards
d'euros la cour des comptes elle parle
de six milliards d'euros
dont qu est ce que vous trouvez le rêve
parce que c'était absolument
d'accord sur ces ouvriers dire où est ce
que je vais trouver l'argent pour
financer tout ça non mais dans
différents centres dit
qu'on n'est pas d'accord sur le
chiffrage j'invite les gens qui nous
regardent à aller regarder sur aime la
france point.fr ou d'autres programmes
est tout à fait chiffrer après là pour
le coup ce sont des questions assez
techno pour rentrer dans les détails il
se trouve que nos experts ont chiffré sa
saisie pourquoi vous pensez que la cour
des comptes non mais je suis moins
d'accord sur les chiffres voilà vous
estimez vous passez en bataille et veut
interroger quand même sur le programme
vous savez encore une fois je voulais
dire on l'a pas écrit sur un bout de
table on l'a écrit avec des experts et
la cour des comptes non plus pas non
mais sûrement mais je ne doute pas
écouté de la faisabilité et du bon
chiffrage de ce programme jt oui vous
voulez baisser la tva de 20 à 5 5% sur
l'énergie or vous savez qu'il faut
l'unanimité en europe pour baisser les
taux de tva est ce que c'est pas du coup
une promesse en l'air non c'est pas du
tout une promesse en l'air parce que
encore une fois c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure il ya un moment où
si vous voulez le peuple est souverain
marine le pen va prendre des décisions
ça m'a coûté un peu cher ça
les boîtiers européenne on est d'accord
mais je en fait je pense qu'il y aura
peut-être un changement de braquet sur
la façon dont on va gouverner mais on
aura la volonté politique de faire ça et
on le fera excusez moi on l'avait fait
quand même
volonté
les restaurateurs un moment on est bien
passé de 20 à 5 5 et ça s'est très bien
passé donc je ne doute pas que ça
fonctionne très bien encore une fois et
que nous n'aurons pas de bâtons dans les
roues pour et c'était une mesure de bon
sens qui redonnera de l'air aux français
parce qu'on va gagner à peu près 10
euros par plein et chaque tâche en
conférence ea coûterait cher à l'état
mais sarah ça pourrait très bien
maintenant c'est 40 euros par mois vous
savez c'est pas c'est pas rien s'est
plaint gardois bentley ont fait au
minimum au minimum sept français sur dix
ont besoin de prendre leur voiture et
sept français de ses sept français
l'habitat plus de travail à plus de 40
km quand on fait tous ces calculs là on
arrive à peu près à 10 euros par plein
il n'empêche que oui c'est vrai chiffre
et ça vaut 12 milliards 12 milliards où
on va aller chercher aussi dans la
fraude sociale par exemple la fraude
sociale et fiscale vous savez qui a été
chiffré par challes prat entre 14 et 50
milliards par an pour se mettre tous
d'accord maintenant de 14 milliards mais
14 milliards sur un quinquennat vous
allez voir que ça va nous permettre de
redonner de l'air aux français de rendre
cet argent là aux français alors vous
vous dites dans la restauration ça a
très bien marché en tout cas ça a pu se
faire oui et non parce qu'en réalité des
restaurateurs n'ont pas appliqué cette
baisse la sur les prix des plats au
restaurant il s'est en fait les marges
des restaurants augmenté donc là en fait
comment vous êtes si certains que la
répercussion se verra bien sûr que la
répercussion sera et puis c'est pas eu
jusqu'à maintenant il ya une autre et
percussions qui va se voir tiens puisque
vous laisser la parole pour en parler et
vous avez vu quand même que l'union
européenne est en train un peu de
camoufler les sanctions sur l'embargo du
pétrole russe et c'est le new york times
qui a sorti l'article alors clément
bonin
même que ça va faire flamber les prix à
la pompe est que l'union européenne a
demandé est ce que ça ne soit fait qu'à
partir du 25 avril c'est à dire après la
présidentielle pour que ça n'aille pas
dans le sens de marine le pen qui dit
qu'on va avoir alors un phénomène qui
ont réellement wallace et déjà déclaré
que cela vienne travailler moi je sais
mais là aussi non au sérieux ont depuis
des semaines et des semaines bien dormir
rien de cacher rien de
chimique c'était bien la volonté de
l'union européenne et cela de ce n'est
pas un peu grosses que ça commence le 25
ans je sais pas revenons une question
sur la tva
c'est pas une mesure qui est finalement
antisociale et très injuste la tva ça
bénéficier à tout le monde vous voulez
pas ciblées vers les personnes les plus
modestes tout le monde veut dire tout le
monde a droit à avoir sa tva qui
baissent je dire je me souviens très
bien il y avait un candidat qui disait
qu'il allait faire ça simplement vous
souvenez sur les gens qui travaillent
ils voulaient que la moitié des 2 des
pleins d'essence soient pris par exemple
par les entreprises et moi je trouvais
ça injuste parce que par exemple la mère
de famille qui doit amener ses enfants
chez l'orthodontiste
noël les moyens le faire c'est au pas
mieux cibler non voulez critiquer aussi
le fait que l'on baissait les prix de
l'essence en chine mais justement je
pense que c'est une mesure elle sait
juste qu'il va bénéficier à tous les
français qui je vous rappelle sorte de
cinq ans de macron fracturé un peu sur
les genoux le pouvoir d'achat s'est
effondré et que non c'est cette mesure
justement elle est passible et vers les
plus modernes ont juste à me rassure
aussi sur le fait que vous ne voulez pas
que les moins de 30 ans paye d'impôts
non m bape et vous allez me parler des
maps et là je vous ai coupé l'herbe sous
mes yeux maintenant j'ai parlé parlé des
maps m et du fait que ce sont
effectivement les français qui gagnent
mieux leur vie qu'ils payent des impôts
fort logiquement il ya pas mal de
français notamment jeunes qui n'en
paient pas donc est-ce que ça va pas là
aussi être une mesure un peu anti
sociales structurelles à favoriser aussi
une mesure si vous voulez qui fait qu'on
va miser sur notre jeunesse c'est qu'on
n'a pas envie que notre jeunesse nos
entrepreneurs même ceux qui gagnent de
l'argent s'en aille et que justement de
de les aider à rester là et a prospéré
et à entreprendre permet aussi de
recréer un tissu industriel de recherche
et que non justement cette mesure bah
tout son sens en soutien justement là
j'ai fait c'est pas parce qu'ils payent
trop d'impôts qui partagent pas d'autres
raisons effectivement les jeunes qui
gagnent mal leur vie bah ils payent pas
d'impôts et ceux qui payent à une trame
est un leurre mais il n'en paieront pas
non plus c'est en ça que
c'est un prisme qui est pas tout à fait
le même je pense qu'effectivement nous
sur cette jeunesse est aussi sur la
jeunesse qui travaillent on a d'autres
mesures pour savez que c'est un constat
optionnel
mais vous assure encore une fois ça va
être l'enfer
une dernière en suisse on parlera pas ce
que vous prévoyez un freak site qui ne
dit pas son nom là encore c'est le fric
si la sécurité de tous et c'est la
question du tout alors clément bonne
avec notamment et bien ce que vous
prévoyez votre baisse de 5 milliards à
la contribution du budget de l'union
européenne ou encore la supériorité de
la loi nationale sur le droit européen
est ce que tout ça c'est possible de le
faire sans faire un freak site non mais
vous voyez on a réfléchi et on s'est dit
que finalement on allait arriver à
changer de l'intérieur sens en tout cas
c'est ce qui ne l'est pas dans les
autres soit d'accord et il
attendait les autres ils passent leur
vie à négocier alors qu emmanuel macron
n'a absolument rien négocié ces
dernières années on a ainsi on peut très
bien les négocier notre contribution
nette je vous rappelle qu'on donne quand
même plus à l'union européenne que ce
qui revient et la ja ne m'en étais la
négociation a eu lieu il ya donc deux
ans ça donne en expliquant avec la
grande bretagne non mais non on
s'arrêter là résultat vous voyez c'est
pas du tout une volonté de quitter
l'europe fait d'éléments bonne partie et
clément bollée juste avant ça peut vous
intéresser c'est qu'effectivement nous
si on va voir si marine le pen va voir
bruxelles en disant de 5 milliards de
moins et bien l'allemagne ou si elle
dira je serai clair de moins et tous les
pays et finalement on aura moins que on
aura encore moins de l'europe donc losio
réunion
soit l'intérêt veut également à ce qu
elle est restée là je pense que monsieur
puisqu'on peut avoir une coopération de
ces nations mais évidemment il ya des
sujets sur lesquels typiquement la
recherche typiquement l'industrie ça
peut être intéressant comme on avait eu
ariane évidemment après effectivement
vous avez que l'on est très attaché à
nos frontières nationales que l'espace
schengen il faut dire aussi aux gens qui
nous écoutent que dès que quelqu'un
j'allais dire un un migrant met le pied
par exemple sur n'importe quel sur
n'importe quel pays de schengen c'est
comme s'il était en france gère on a le
droit aussi de pas être d'accord je vous
rappelle aussi de quoi vous souhaitez
toujours accepte vous l'avez vous l'avez
souhaité y avait annoncé 11 et a vu tout
ce qui vous évite de dire à la fin pour
accueillir un livre réalisé par an on
s'est aperçu quand on pouvait très bien
arriver à le changer de l'intérieur
comme ça va changer la vie de tout seul
évidemment qu'il y aura des négociations
vous savez c'est pour ça que marine le
pen indique son premier déplacement ça
sera d'aller à bruxelles et d'aller
négocier sûrement âprement le meilleur
mais oui il faut que je vais dire vous
savez les français n'étaient pas très
poinçonnet vous cette union européenne
et la façon
dont on en est aujourd'hui
ses preuves je sais pas vous avez trouvé
typiquement pour la crise sanitaire
faisait ses
pensées mais vous plaisantez ou quoi ces
derniers on a on a été les marais on va
pas refaire vraie balle est passée par
là dire bah l'immigration c'est une
europe qui a fait ses preuves est ce que
vous pensez à une robe je finis juste un
seul week a vraiment vous parler très
vite et le respect je veux être convoyé
l'irlande qui était contre le traité de
lisbonne et que l'europe a fait voter
voter vont trouver que ça fonctionnait
mal je veux dire non c'est une rumeur
respecte pas les peuples merci brigitte
merci tam mais quand même vous dit
marine le pen voulait sortir de l'europe
il est français les français ne
voulaient pas sortir de l'europe et
finalement elle vaut rester dans
l'europe donc elles fonctionnent
suffisamment bas pour que les français
ils soient suffisamment attaché donc
où on va négocier où on va j'allais dire
défendre notre bout de gras ce qui est
pas fait depuis longtemps va aussi
réfléchir à ce couple franco-allemand
qui n'existe pas quand on dit un couple
c'est une histoire d'amour les deux sont
censés être en couple vraisemblablement
là nous étions seuls d'accord est
effectivement marine le pen en
conférence de presse récemment estimé
que ce couple n'était pas
dysfonctionnelle mais en tout cas
qu'elle voulait en finir avec cette
relation privilégiée avec berlin c'est
avec elle ce qui ouvre là aussi un des
terres inconnues mais je vous présentais
vous le connaissez istréens
alors dans 48 heures il ya un débat la
france va être concentrée sur ce débat
marine le pen aussi elle avait
complètement raté son débat ya cinq ans
comme vous y allez ben ah bon elle avait
trébuché à c'est tout bon elle avait dit
monde l'a reconnu elle-même que c'était
pas un grand succès bon le sujet c'est
maintenant
c'est quoi l'enjeu pour vous de ce débat
pour marine le pen
l'enjeu pour ce débat c'est d'aller
chercher les abstentionnistes c'est
d'aller convaincre tous les gens qui
n'ont pas voté pour nous vous savez
quand vous allez dans la rue sept
français sur dix n'ont plus envie d'
emmanuel macron veulent changer
président de la république il se trouve
que tous ces gens là n'ont pas voté pour
nous au premier tour nous ont quand même
porté au second tour et donc ça va être
tout l'enjeu de présenter notre
programme est de bien montrer si vous
voulez l'espèce de grosse dichotomique
lien entre eux entre nos deux programmes
qui est 6ème fondamentalement différent
précisément quand on regarde un peu et
qu'on fait de l'arithmétique avec les
reports de voix des gens qui sont
proches de marine le pen on se dit qu'il
ya du retard il ya un sacré retard et
que vous allez en ce moment chercher des
voies d'un candidat qui est à l'opposé
de ce que vous êtes vous n'auriez pas
nationaliste mais qui est d'extrême
gauche alors comment vous faites qu'on
est nationaliste extrême par une autre
question faudrait nous inviter sur un
autre bateau pour qu'on en parle je ne
pense pas je pense typiquement sur les
la retraite je vois mal comment les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon vont
pouvoir aller donner leur voix à
quelqu'un qui est pour la retraite à 65
ans quelqu'un qui a été voilà des signes
et fiscales au bout de cinq ans de
maquereau le
pauvre mais pas tous pas tous détrompez
vous les pauvres sont plus pauvres et
les riches sont plus riches c'est
quelqu'un ce sont des électeurs avec qui
on a eu pas mal de points communs
notamment dans la bataille du pass
liberticide du pass sanitaire
souvenez-vous matile panneaux souvenez
vous monsieur rufin sommet du canal
jusqu'à elles sont tombées à tous encore
pas tous vous assure je pense qu'en fait
sur l'échiquier politique
et c'est en ça que le clivage est très
différent c'est parce qu'en fait chez
les souverainistes vous en avez de tous
bords souvenez vous quand marine le pen
disait de montebourg jusqu'à zemmour
sans quoi sa maman chantal est même
qualifiée de national et non mais parce
que c'est un grand bond non mais je sais
très bien que dans la bouche vous et moi
ce n'est pas du tout
quand il était un petit peu péjoratif
surtout entre deux tours où on
s'accroche pour les turbulences voilà
souvent il ya un petit côté péjoratif
mais moi je suis très attaché à la
nation je suis très attaché à la
souveraineté de notre pays dont vous
inquiétez pas je le gros problème aussi
que les gens s'interrogent chez madame
le pen gagne les élections par exemple
l'élection présidentielle mais avec qui
gouverne hôtel avec thibaut vingtaine
mais figurez-vous qu'on avait lu un
papier dans le figaro récemment de
quelqu'un qui est bien informé que vous
connaissez charles sapin qui dit elle a
pas les moyens de faire un gouvernement
moi je pense qu'elle en fait trois des
gouvernements bien sûr qu'elles ont fait
trois garnements non c'est pas
dsk est-ce que vous connaissiez agnès
buzyn en espagne r une hache et monsieur
bonne ce sont des gens qu'on a découvert
et je peux vous dire que à l'assemblée
je suis à l'intérieur de notre parti je
vais pas vous prenez thierry mariani
ancien ministre monsieur gare aux
anciens ministres passent culièrement
discret d'ailleurs monsieur marc on
n'entend pas
pour longtemps par monsieur
mariani
si si si vous tuez si vous serez sans
appoint temps
le cheval mais si on suivait sans son
twitter je vous assure qu'il tweet
encore et que c'est un soutien de marine
sans aucun problème il pourrait utiliser
affaires étrangères agences et rien
aucune idée ça pour le coup du du
gouvernement et puis vous savez marine
le pen dit qu'elle veut un gouvernement
d'union nationale et je pense
qu'effectivement au bout de cinq ans où
le peuple sort fracturé comme jamais il
faut peut-être que des sensibilités qui
se retrouve évidemment les courants
d'extrême gauche en fait elle le dit
elle le dis très simplement elle dit je
ne prendrai personnes dont la
philosophie contreviendrait évidemment
avec son projet profond on est bien
d'accord après il est évident qu'il ya
quand même des 10 sujets sur lesquels on
arrivera à se retrouver et puis vous
savez quand on gagne on agrège
figurez-vous les gens viennent à vous
aussi et les gens proposent leurs
services alors justement il ya des
élections législatives mettons mettons
nous dans la position d'une victoire de
madame le pen ce qui vous fait plaisir
venez à moi ce qui vous fait plaisir il
ya des élections législatives comment
vous faites avec un scrutin qui n'est
pas un scrutin importe rationnelle pour
avoir un nombre de dés lui suffisant
afin de gouverner alors que là
aujourd'hui eh bien vous voyez bien que
vous avez même pas un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale met d'ailleurs je
suis je vous remercie de mettre le doigt
là dessus parce qu'il ya un vrai
problème et c'est la raison pas comment
nous faudrait la proportionnelle parce
que je rappelle encore aux gens qui nous
écoutent 11 millions d'électeurs et six
députés
si ça c'est pas un scandale démocratique
c'est
la proportionnelle tout de suite ça on
pourra pas le faire que la notion on
pourra pas l'appliquer comme ça ce qui
est certain c'est que si marine le pen
gagnon ça veut dire qu'on fait des très
gros score et que et enfin on fait un
gros score et que le gros score en
national il se répercute bien évidemment
dans nos régions typiquement moi je vais
vous dire en paca si marine le pen gagne
je peux vous dire que des députés on va
en passer beaucoup n'ont pas l'occasion
de se revoir pourquoi toujours pas
soirée bokuma parce qu'on arrive en tête
partout par exemple en paca on arrive en
tête en paca on arriverait en tête dans
le var on arrive même en tête je vais
vous dire à toulon bastion d'hubert
falco donc ça voudrait dire évidemment
tu auras une vague derrière un peu comme
la vague dont emmanuel macron a
bénéficié souvenez-vous où là encore on
a eu des députés qui n'est sorti de
nulle part il ne connaissait est ce que
dans cet entre-deux-tours puisque vous
on parle beaucoup de jean luc mélenchon
mais il ya aussi la droite
des républicains qui s'appelle les
républicains est-ce que vous avez
cherché à l'est et bien par exemple
monsieur ciotti qui a dit qu'il ne
voterait pas pour emmanuel macron est-ce
qu'ils pourraient voter pour votre
candidat on va voir on va attendre de
voir où ils avaient alors j'ai passé un
coup de fil au relais dans les
tractations moi je ne peux pas répondre
à votre question moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est vrai que eric ciotti pour moi
c'est un peu une énigme vous savez j'ai
été aux régionales il a appelé à voter
renaud muselier qui était soutenu par la
république en marche dès le premier tour
aux régionales donc c'est vrai que
c'était assez étonnant pour quelqu'un
qui finalement après band est un peu les
murs sur les plateaux en disant ah ben
non moi je suis vraiment de droite il se
trouve que là ils se désolidarisent de
sa candidate voilà je sais pas s'il a eu
des rapports avec en tout cas nous
n'avons pas si vous pouvez nous n'avons
pas d'ennemis dans les gens qui aiment
la france qui croient en la france qui
croient à la consistance qu'on peut
rendre à la france à son industrie assez
et robert ménard juste un mot ou s'est
mis en retrait pourquoi parce qu'elle a
trop critiquer mais non mais c'est lui
qui s'est mis en retrait je pense je
pense qu on est on est d'accord mais
reste en soutien mais il l'a dit très
clairement il reste un soutien de marine
le pen
non mais après je pense que voilà il ya
des points qui sont de désaccord et je
pense qu'il le dit j'ai pas voulu
polluer brouiller le message qu'ils
l'étaient parce qu'il y avait des points
de désaccord ouais donc et on lui a
demandé peut-être non non non non non
non il entend merci nana là c'est fini
merci dans le nord la valette merci vous
avez un débit de mitraillette
je vous le dise ça rime mais merci de
voter ce soir sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques marc si vous êtes une petite
semaine la semaine prochaine on se
retrouve le second tour aura passé
évidemment on accueillera un invité qui
représentera le camp du vainqueur il n'y
a pas de féminin à vainqueur donc ça
peut être une femme bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]